[Music]
you have mentioned on this show before
that you enjoy the occasional indulgence
in marijuana have you they're about to
boo ya have you faced that out I quit
yeah Rasta convention everyone I do
myself every morning boohoo remembering
things feeling things blue human contact
blue but I can quit for a couple reasons
and one of the last times I got high
this is crazy I was up in Portland
Oregon and where it's very very legal
and I was I used to hang out after
comedy shows with strangers after my
stand-up shows I'd go out into the
parking lot with people I didn't know
and whatever stuff they brought with
them I'd smoke which is super safe and
[Laughter]
that's smart and so this is true I'm
hanging out with all these people
there's about 20 of us and they can't
hang and so at the end of it it's just
me and this one guy and he's the super
stoner he's got like a STONER nickname
he calls himself ganja John like he
didn't need a STONER nickname because
it's like dude we can smell you and
we're hanging out and he pulls out his
ID what he hadn't been a big guy right
and that's how he let me know he had a
fake eye he just yanked
[Applause]
which if you have a fake eye I'm sorry
like don't play darts I don't know what
to tell you but use words you know like
if you think it's a good conversation
piece use words tell me you have a fake
guy right then give me the option go hey
would you like to see it so I could
either go yeah yes or no keep that [ __ ]
in your face he just yanked it out he
just yanked it out and I'm high as hell
now there's this black hole in his face
I think demons are gonna fly
[Laughter]